[Música]
en eeuu estalla y la pandemia se
politiza
mientras los líderes demócratas piden
cuarentenas estrictas para reducir el
número de casos los republicanos
encabezados por el presidente trump
piden priorizar medidas que protejan la
economía
[Música]
no vamos a destruir nuestro país tenemos
que regresar porque sabes en cierto
punto perderás más gente de esta manera
con todos los problemas causados que con
lo que estamos haciendo ahora
webber
ante el inminente impacto para los
hogares la casa blanca y el senado
llegan a un acuerdo sobre un paquete de
estímulo de 2 billones de dólares
el 2 de abril el mundo supera el millón
de contagios
mientras china reabrir la ciudad de
wuhan tras un bloqueo de 76 días
nueva york- se convierte en el nuevo
epicentro de la pandemia
y los hospitales están al borde del
colapso
para el 9 de abril el mundo supera las
100.000 muertes de las cuales 14.000 se
han producido en el estado de nueva york
el 14 de abril donald trump rompe con la
misión
hoy le estoy dando instrucciones a mi
administración para que tenga la
financiación de la organización mundial
de la salud mientras se realiza una
revisión para evaluar su papel en el
manejo y el encubrimiento de la
propagación del corona birmingham
[Música]
el 20 de abril una serie de causas entre
ellas la pandemia genera que el petróleo
por primera vez en la historia
cotice en números negativos de nuevo el
presidente de trump hace una polémica
declaración entonces veo que el
desinfectante lo elimina en un minuto
hay alguna manera de que puedas hacer
algo así como una inyección
en reacción ensayos
millones de musulmanes en todo el mundo
celebran desde el 23 de abril el ramadán
el mes sagrado del islám pero la gran
mezquita de la meca está vacía
[Música]
la economía de eeuu pierde 20.5 millones
de puestos de trabajo en abril la mayor
caída desde la gran depresión la tasa de
desempleo sube al 14.7 por ciento
mientras los casos y muertes empiezan a
disminuir en nueva york latinoamérica
preocupa a la oms brasil y méxico-
encabezan la lista de los países más
afectados y sus mandatarios asumen
polémicas posturas frente a la pandemia
después de la puñalada no será un leve
resfriado lo que me derribará vale si el
médico del ministerio de salud
recomienda un nuevo examen lo haré de lo
contrario me comportaré como cualquiera
de ustedes aquí voy de aquí el
coronavirus eso sí no se puede una brasa
hay que abrazarse si no pasa nada
en esta fase de la pandemia de las
imágenes más duras se ven en la ciudad
ecuatoriana de guayaquil desbordada por
los fallecimientos los cuerpos en las
calles y los ataúdes de cartón hacen que
el miedo colectivo se propague
los impactos económicos también se ven
en la región latam bianca a las
aerolíneas más grandes de américa latina
se declaran en bancarrota el 22 de mayo
brasil supera a rusia y se convierte en
el número 2 del mundo en casos
para el 7 de junio las muertes en el
mundo superan las 400 mil y los casos
confirmados se acercan a los 7 millones
europa se prepara para el verano y la
mayoría de los países reabre
gradualmente tenemos el propósito de
garantizar la reactivación del turismo
nacional de cara a esta misma temporada
de verano
[Música]
miles de ciudadanos corren a las costas
y las imágenes de playas abarrotadas se
vuelven una constante se reactivan las
ligas de fútbol y la nueva normalidad se
vive en las calles del viejo continente
[Música]
la crisis en latinoamérica se agudiza
tres presidentes de la región tan
positivo yo sí me diagnosticado que sido
contagiado
por ejemplo si no me hubiera hecho la
prueba de kobe 19 no habría sabido el
resultado y dio positivo
y dado que en la última semana muchos de
ellos dieron positivo al coronavirus me
hice la prueba y también he dado
positivo
el 11 de julio trump usa cubrebocas en
público por primera vez durante una
visita a un hospital militar las últimas
semanas de julio varios países de
latinoamérica empiezan a relajar sus
medidas
sin embargo en europa el sol del verano
se empieza a ocultar de nuevo